(city noises)
(Jersey club beat)
- That kick pattern.
Yeah, you know the one I'm talking about.
(upbeat music)
That's a staple of the Jersey Club sound,
a sound that's gone viral
across YouTube and TikTok,
making the whole world shake their hips.
You've probably heard
the Jersey Club remixes
that have gone viral online.
(upbeat music)
Or maybe you've heard
Jersey Club's influence
in top 40 hits like Level Up by Ciara.
♪ Level up ♪
♪ Level up, level up, level up ♪
If you've been on TikTok, then
you definitely know this song
by Jersey native, Cookiee Kawaii.
♪ Throw it back, throw it back ♪
♪ Back, back, throw it back ♪
This sound originates from the Black DJs
of the Newark club scene,
and even though online data
shows that more women are
listening to Jersey Club than men,
the music production has been
historically male-dominated.
Recently, however,
there's been a rise in women producers
making club music.
But before we get into that story,
let's rewind a bit and talk about
where Jersey Club came from.
Sound Field went to Newark, New Jersey,
to meet the dancers and
producers who make this music
and to find out what makes
this sound so contagious.
(upbeat music)
♪ I'm gonna leave it on the dance floor ♪
(crowd yelling)
So where did Jersey club come from?
On the surface,
it's a hybrid of the
original Newark club sound
and the Chicago house sound.
The Jersey sound was birthed in the 80s
at the legendary Zanzibar nightclub
in Newark, New Jersey
by musical icon, Tony Humphries.
Humphries' music blended electronic beats
with soulful melodies,
becoming a staple in the nightclub scene.
(upbeat music)
But it wasn't until the early 2000s
that it became the Jersey club
sound you recognize today.
- It came a time where
the Chicago records stopped coming.
So I was like, yo, I need something fresh.
- DJ Tameil,
a pioneer in the club
scene would travel to
Music Liberated, a hotspot
for local DJs in Baltimore.
- We constantly went and bought vinyls.
So I would just read all the
credits, all of the names,
you know, the numbers,
I called the number on it.
The first guy I got in
touch with was this guy
named Bernie, rest in peace to Bernie.
But he was like one of the
biggest labels down there.
They would take all of
the B-more producers,
artists, and this and that.
And you know, he'll put
their records out for him
and he owned his own record store.
So, you know, when I would call him
he would just introduce
me to different people.
- It was there that he met Baltimore DJs,
like DJ Technics and Rod Lee,
who gave him the blessing
to take the Baltimore style
back to Newark.
(upbeat music)
I would just roam around here,
find everybody,
kick it with them.
You know, we produced tracks together.
We had no idea that it was
going to turn into this
right here.
- It was this blending of styles
that gave birth to brick city club music,
which quickly became popular
across the state of New Jersey.
Listen to the kick pattern
in Teena Marie Theme by DJ Tameil.
(upbeat music)
After Tameil,
more and more Jersey DJs began
making their own club hits,
and gaining millions of plays online.
DJs like Slink, Montana, and Lilman
(upbeat music)
Then in 2009,
women began to move from the
dance floor to the DJ booth.
That's when UNIIQU3 hit the scene.
This is UNIIQU3.
The queen of Jersey club,
a producer, artist, and DJ
who's propelling this 135 BPM genre
into a global phenomenon.
(upbeat music)
♪ Everybody say woo woo ♪
♪ Woo woo ♪
- So in your own words
how would you describe Jersey club music?
- Jersey club music is
your morning coffee,
it's your afternoon red bull,
it's your late night espresso shot,
it's rambunctious in
your face party music.
- And what was it like for women
in the club scene when you got started?
- Right. Well, when I came up,
it was super male dominated.
We had a couple of women,
come and MC on tracks,
like Ms. Porsh.
She was one of the first
women I heard on a club track,
and I was just like, yo, this is hot.
We need more of this.
We need girls DJing too.
I'm a part of the second
generation of club music.
There wasn't really a
blueprint for me to look up to.
It was very, just dude behind the DJ booth
and all the girls would be,
you know, dancing,
shaking it to the left and the right.
Not a lot of female representation
other than on the dance floor.
(upbeat music)
Can you let me know who were some people
in the Jersey club world that
you look up to right now?
Who really inspires you?
- Queen and Kia.
- Top two.
- Yeah. And I really don't
know no other dancers.
Male dancers, that's all I know.
And those are the only two females.
- So, and how come, you know,
you think that there's not enough girls
in the Jersey club culture representing.
- They don't get enough
opportunities, in my opinion.
- Right.
- They don't get to go out
there and show their talent
like they want to, in my opinion.
- Not like the boys do.
- Yeah, the boys y'all out there.
Thinking they're all that.
And you know, some girls,
men don't know, some
girls can go out there.
And just steal the spotlight, just saying.
(upbeat music)
- I just feel like females,
maybe they don't see other UNIIQU3s.
Like who do you think
you have to look up to
To be like, I can do it.
But now that there's
somebody like Uniique3
and other female DJs out here doing it.
Maybe they can be like, you know what?
I don't have to be shaking my
booty in front of the camera.
Maybe I can be behind the
scenes, making the music
that's making people shake their booties.
(upbeat music)
- There are more women now taking over.
Basically when it comes
to, like I say, UNIIQU3,
she's one of the main girls.
Cookiees out here.
She's doing her thing.
It's just before there
were all men, that's it.
It's all men scratching.
And now you just feel
way more comfortable.
(crowd talking)
- We have something so unique in our state
and within Jersey club,
like there's no way that it
shouldn't be on the big screen
or mainstream or anywhere like.
UNIIQU3 done started it,
Slink done started it.
Everybody done just took it further.
So it was like the best part about it is
the fact that a female
is even taking it even further
on top of other females.
So that's just the dopest part about it.
And it deserves to go everywhere.
Everybody listening, tune in
on SoundCloud to DJ UNIIQU3.
and Cookiee Kawaii,
everybody! So.
(laughing)
- In Jersey, the ecosystem is composed of
four working parts.
Music, dance, business, and community.
So what exactly makes a Jersey club song,
a Jersey club song?
You remember that kick pattern?
(beat music)
This rhythm is an essential ingredient
in the Jersey club sound,
and it was inspired by Baltimore club.
- Oh, all of that stems
from, I don't know,
can I say that on here?
Okay. Well it was a
record called Dikkontrol.
(upbeat music)
My partner Technics, which, you know,
I highly look up to just,
I got a lot of respect for him,
like how people got respect for me.
And he blew my mind when he told me.
He was in a DMZ DJ battle in 1993
and was juggling records
back and forth and did that
beat on the turntables.
They went back to the studio
and recorded it and it became a club beat.
But that one record we stuck to,
and we just took that kick pattern
and just kept going with it.
You know? So we just built from there.
- Another thing that
Jersey club is famous for
is their use of sampling.
- You know, anything we
can sample, we will use it.
And that's what Jersey club is.
I mean, Jersey club, B-more
club is sampled bass.
The bed squeaks,
which everybody thinks is a bed squeak.
Lil John explained that,
which was mind blowing for us
because we always thought
it was a bed squeak.
It's not a bed squeak.
(upbeat music)
Lil John explained that
it's a rocking chair.
But it sounds like a bed spring.
But you know, we ran with it.
It's still a bed spring to us.
(upbeat music)
♪ Give it to me, give it
to me, give it to me ♪
- As the music continues to evolve,
its sound has become more aggressive.
Today, club tracks
switch up their four, four beat pattern
every eight to 16 bars.
Then there's the vocals,
usually chopped up
samples of top 40 tracks,
along with column responsible pools
from independent artists
or the DJs themselves.
- The way that we chop up our vocals
are so clever because
at the end of the day,
it all has to lead to
making somebody dance.
I just usually try to
find the best cadence.
♪ Hands up, ♪
♪ I'm gonna do my thing. ♪
Yeah. It came from a freestyle,
so I think I was just like,
spitting in my mic saying different stuff,
getting warmed up.
And I was like, man,
this kind of sounds dope.
♪ Back let me get it on the dance floor ♪
♪ Stand back i'mma leave
it on the dance floor ♪
♪ Stand back, stand back, stand back ♪
- Another important part of
Jersey club culture is remixing.
And Jersey producers have
even helped other artists
Go viral through their club remixes.
- We find these records and
we make them cross over.
So a drill trap record
that you wouldn't hear
at a certain demographic party,
you could play it now,
because what we do is we transform it
into something that's
relatable to a wider audience.
(upbeat music)
- But it's not just remixes,
Jersey Club Producers are also
putting out original dance music
that's played at clubs and
festivals around the world.
- Even though Jersey club
is known for its remixes
We have a plethora of
original Jersey club content
from you know, even UNIIQU3, you know,
being one of the curator
for the first ever
Spotify Jersey club playlist.
There's a lot of original
content on that playlist.
(upbeat music)
- There's only one rule
at Jersey club parties,
and that rule is simple.
Everyone must move to the beat.
There are even step-by-step
instructions in the music.
So there's no excuse to be standing still.
The use of call and
response dance instructions,
and the evolution of the Jersey club sound
naturally gave weight to organize dances.
- So I, so if you want to
talk Jersey club, right?
A lot of times we're talking DJs,
talking producers, we're
talking the artists, right?
But we don't exist
without the cornerstone of
what Jersey club was made for,
which is the dancer, right?
It's the reason why
Jersey Club was popular.
When nobody knew what Jersey club was,
when they were in their dorm rooms,
and it had no title to the genre,
they were playing patty-cake.
They were playing footwork, percolator,
all these things because it made you move.
It was something to dance to,
and dance is universal.
- The reason why people
respond that way is because
traditionally in Africa, it's
a call to call and response.
So when the person bangs the drum,
the person dances.
The purpose of us dancing back then,
in those times were to
call upon our ancestors.
So the call is the,
(patting)
and the response is the dance.
- As the dance culture
surrounding Jersey clubs
spread throughout the state,
new DJs began to emerge
with their dance crews
known as street teams.
The dance moves that
premiered alongside the music
became the highlight of the parties.
- Like how did you make the running man?
You know what I'm saying?
Like, like, like that's just
so creative and it went viral.
You know what I'm saying?
It was on Fortnite.
It was on Ellen.
You heard it here first.
Like that's a whole viral dance.
Like how did you come
up with the running man?
- It's not like I sat home and you know,
was like, you go left over right.
Though the terminology that
people use today is labbing.
So when you're labbing,
you know what I'm saying?
You just start coming up with stuff
and you just start doing stuff.
And it's like a groove.
You know what I'm saying?
And that groove is what
people latched on to.
You know what I'm saying?
(crowd yelling)
- Jersey club isn't just music and dance.
It's energy, life, and community,
creating a safe space for the
young people of New Jersey.
- It takes the kids off
the streets in my opinion.
It saves a lot of people.
There's a lot of gang violence
where we all come from.
Irvington, Orange, East Orange, Newark,
a bunch of gang violence,
a lot of broken families.
So kids try to,
it's like an outlet for a
lot of us is like, love.
We get love from everybody.
And everybody's so in tune with it.
So it saves, it literally saves everybody.
It brings happiness.
- I started off as a rough
kid, went gang banger.
I did basketball, gang
bangin' and basketball
was my only thing, my option.
Dancing kind of saved me
and I've been through real life stuff.
So my way to cope was dancing.
It became more spiritual,
11 years later I'm here still doing it.
(crowd yelling)
- These days, it's easy to see
how the women of Jersey club are helping
to push the genre into the future.
But back in the early 2000s,
there was a legendary DJ
who laid the groundwork
by lifting club music to new heights.
Can you tell us how much
K-Swift means to you?
- Rest in peace K-Swift,
Baltimore club queen,
the club queen period.
K-Swift meant so much to me,
but there was definitely a
big void when she passed away.
- K-Swift was a legendary
DJ from Baltimore.
Her tragic death in 2008
left behind a hole in
the local music scene.
- K-Swift was like the
face for B-more Club.
Wherever she went, you know,
people just followed her,
and they loved her for what she did.
You know, she was phenomenal.
- She was a woman, a black woman
that was carrying the torch to
bringing Baltimore club music
and East coast club music
in general to new heights.
- Her death took a toll
on a lot of people, man.
I feel like, you know,
after she passed away
I mean the city as a whole, you know
as far as playing club music,
it kind of just fell apart.
Everybody just kind of lost his steam.
Like, you know,
like that sucked the life
out of everybody man.
- Me and my home girl,
TT the artist from Baltimore,
she's Baltimore's club queen,
and I'm Jersey club queen.
We doing our best to try to represent
K-Swift and a bright light and,
you know finish the work
that she started real tall.
Just as K-Swift's legacy
inspired the musicians of today,
today's artists are already
inspiring the next generation.
- When I first saw Maji,
like I was so in awe
I was like, look at this
young girl killing it.
I never saw that in my whole life.
After that, I just, you
know, made it my business.
Like I have to work with this young girl.
(upbeat music)
♪ Slow it down, slow
it down, slow it down ♪
♪ Slow it down, down, slow it down ♪
♪ Slow it down, slow
it down, slow it down ♪
♪ Down, down, down ♪